i was never that good at skateboarding
but like with street skating because it
was in its infancy i was like
almost like kind of like advancing with
like the you know like the yeah the
the general progression of it right so
and and you being a vert skater and i
could say this you know probably about
like a you know a handful of vert
skaters
like i you know i was sort of we were at
the same level oh for sure
so now this is where it gets
embarrassing for me
because fast forward all these years and
i'm out of control on drugs
i mean lost my mind and i'm broadcasting
my downward spiral
to a like a list of like 200 people
oh the rad the rat were you on that yeah
yeah briefly
here's here's the thing is that i had
it was the most influential people who
like had the misfortune
of me getting a hold of their contact
info all on one email list like the most
all cc'd you could see the whole list
[Laughter]
right and and at one point at one point
after the
what i called the rad email list started
um
i uh i got an email knoxville made the
mistake
of sending a mass email list with
everybody on copy you could see everyone
on copy
so i just copied and pasted like his
knoxville's entire email is and then
added it to my
my rad email is so now but then he got
full
that's now tony hawk has landed on my
rad email list because he was in
knoxville's
you know like so now like no
tony hawk's getting this like oh like a
daily rap
which is awful or like i'm stevo's mad
at somebody's growing off or like
stevo's discovered a new dimension
you know like it was really really
gnarly stuff and a lot of people are
glued to it because it was just such a
train wreck
but tony being the good guy that he is
wasn't interested in no no what happens
what um was he said
the red email list has become full
i can't add anyone else so if anyone
wants out
let me know and i was like i'm out
i don't know but i said i said i i i'm
out because i don't have time to read
all of them i was trying to be
as pragmatic as possible how long were
they i mean
it could have been pages sometimes or
just some yeah some rap
it could have been it might have been a
video it might have been an essay
i mean they they exist somewhere yeah so
so basically i just said like
think i i i don't have time to read it
right now yeah
that was it and he wasn't interested in
the train wreck i mean he's just a good
guy
he's like yo like i'm good i don't like
you know this so this doesn't make me
watch what you wish for right and then
and so now now i
i received this from from tony hawk and
i'm just like
what and i'm like so i start with
everybody on copy
i start attacking tony and i'm like
and i'm like i started tagging with
everybody on like the whole thing and
i'm like
you like you were never even that rad
you know like like he said i was like
you were never even that red
i ripped over you at street skating
oh my god i remember reading that gun
yeah probably yeah you're just like
sober having coffee like yeah
you're right sure yeah but let the
record reflect that now that i have
like painstakingly gone through the last
30 years of footage of me skating
and like i was not even close to as good
at street skating at tony hawk
i mean and anybody can can see this
because now i've got
my untold story of stevo's skateboard
video career you can you know you can
wait is that wall ride thing up now it's
not up yet but
by the time this comes out it will be
the untold story of stevo's skateboard
career and uh don't let the word maybe
that was our reckoning was the wall ride
right yeah i did the wall ride but yeah
yeah you did that there it is there it
is there it is
yeah that's true you did it front side
you did a front side
with that tire you did it like six times
like warming up waiting for you to do it
you did it
every time yeah
so so uh i know that i've said this in
the past but let me just say it uh you
know for
for the public record like that was
like the most embarrassing thing for me
and uh for you to have forgiven me
for that and and gone on to be such a
good guy such a
such a dear friend and and always you
know generous with your time whenever
i've got some
dumb idea like this one i just want to
say i'm sorry for that and
thank you oh it was it was uh
i say it's a good story yeah it was fun
did you guys i remember
i got into there i'm sure there were a
lot of background conversations
happening in this email that he was you
know because i was just like dude he was
looking at this
i don't remember jerry nothing was in
the background yeah
but gary delavate he was on the way
he emailed me about something else i did
the wrap-up show one time
and uh he was like hey man were you on
that stevo list i was like yes
and then i said i had to i had to get
out and he was like you could just
feel the drugs in the emails oh my god
oh dude like name some other people yeah
they were on there yeah
yeah what year was this like i said 2007
and then the first few months of 2008
and then i got sober and then
did you guys ever run into each other
right after that like i don't remember
right after that like
i remember tony reaching out to me to do
his uh serious
xm radio show and were you like [ __ ] and
i was like oh my god like
i can't even i can't even believe that
tony actually wants like
to have something to do with me like i
was like embarrassed
to see tony i think and uh that like for
him to reach out
like and and i was just there was so
much so much healing in that you know
did you do it at the show yeah yeah for
sure i did the show
talk about that on the show or your
number one i'm sure we did i don't know
i
feel like i remembered it but it was
just it was just such a mess
it was just like who cares like it was
just so you were sober at that point
right yeah
sure i mean i've been sober ever since
the the rat email list and and
and i can even say pretty definitively
that i've been sober
ever since because of the rat email list
i mean dude like like this whole period
everything was
it was just such a it was such a cry for
help
yeah in in disguise where everyone's
reading and going
we gotta do something here yeah this
can't go on and then
didn't you schedule like you were like
you made the man like i'm going to
[ __ ] jump out the window
you better get a camera crew over here
i'm going to jump out the window and
uh knoxville said okay we'll be there
great i
love tony hawk and he's raising money to
build
skate parks by selling a limited number
of these
hand signed legendary photos
and there's a link in the bio to get one
so help
tony hawk build skate parks
okay buy a hand signed
freaking print yeah dude
yeah dude